Let's start allowing the ports
we know we'll need for
the applications our
server will be supporting.
First and foremost we know
we'll need to support SSH so
we can continue
administering this server.
Normally you would do this by
typing sudo ufw allow ssh and
you can go ahead and do that now.
But remember, we're using
a Vagrant virtual machine and
Vagrant set up our SSH on Port 2222.
So we'll need to allow all TCP
connections through Port 2222 for
SSH to actually work
in our scenario here.
For now, the only other application we
plan to support is a basic HTTP server,
so we can allow this by
using sudo ufw allow www.
And with that, we can now enable
our firewall with sudo ufw enable.
This step here can be
a little hair raising,
because our SSH connection is reliant
upon these rules being correct.
If all of a sudden you lose your
SSH connection to your server,
it's a pretty clear indicator that
you messed up some of your rules.
Some cloud providers do offer a way
to regain access to your system
through an external control panel.
But many others,
you're just out of luck at this point.
For this reason,
I recommend configuring your firewall
pretty early in
the server setup process.
Finally, we can confirm all of our
rules are set up as we indicated
by using the sudo ufw status command.
We'll see all of our rules here and
that our firewall is currently active.